mr speaker when owen patterson was on
the ropes the prime minister was
prepared to rip up the entire rule book
to save his jobs
piano workers want him to show the same
fight in relation to them
the government had advanced warning of
these mass sackings
a memo was sent to the transport
secretary and to the prime minister's
office
but they didn't lift a finger to stop
them
did the prime minister not understand
the memo or did he just not bother to
read it
my minister i think what uh what the
right honourable gentleman needs to rip
up mr speaker is these pre-scripted
questions
because i've just i've just answered
i've just answered the question and the
point the point at issue the pointed
issue mr speaker is whether or not the
government was properly notified and it
doesn't and it's not about what happens
the previously i knew about it on the
thursday it became public but the the
company concerned has a duty uh to
notify the government 45 days uh mr
speaker before they take action of that
kind that is why we're taking the action
that we are to protect hard-working
people and what we're also doing by the
way mr speaker this month is lifting the
living wage for all workers across our
country uh by another thousand pounds so
it's up five thousand pounds since 2015.
[Music]
[Applause]
i think the prime minister just said he
knew about it on the day yeah i take it
from that answer the prime minister
didn't read his whatsapp briefing
let's test his rhetoric
mr speaker since the prime minister came
to office
piano have received
over 38 million pounds of government
contracts
and the parent company dp world is lined
up for 50 million pounds of taxpayers
money under the freeport scheme
the government is apparently reviewing
these contracts but reviews don't save
like save jobs
can the prime minister guarantee
guarantee that these companies will not
get a penny more of taxpayers money or a
single tax break until they reinstate
the workforce
mr speaker i think what uh house has
already heard is that we are taking
legal action against the against yes we
are against the company concerned under
under the 1992 uh employment uh and
trades union and labor relation uh act
and that is the the right thing to do
because it seems to me mr speaker that
they have broken the law but if he is
asking if he's asking this government to
do what labor usually want us to do and
actively pitchfork away investment
around the country from overseas mr
speaker then that is not what we will do
we'll take him to court we'll defend the
rights of british workers what we will
not do mr speaker is launch a
wholehearted campaign as they would want
against overseas investment because that
isn't that is completely wrong and wrong
for those workers mr speaker
[Applause]
well dp world must be quaking in their
boots
the primitive says how disappointed he
is in them whilst handing them 50
million pounds
sp
said about the law speaking of hollow
reviews
as the law stands it's not illegal to
pay seafarers below the national minimum
wage
even if they're even if they're working
out of uk ports and in uk waters
two years ago prime minister his
government
admitted that that was unjustifiable two
years ago and promised two years ago
you've guessed it
to review it
two years on despite what he says today
nothing's been done leaving the gate
wide open for pno
british workers don't need another empty
review they need action so when will the
primes to fix that gap in the law
mr speaker with great humility i must
ask the right normal gentleman to listen
to the answer that i gave
to the first question uh because it
would then help him uh to scrap his
third or fourth question and try another
one uh we are we are going to address
the uh the defects in the 1998
living wage act uh minimum wage act and
make sure that everybody everybody is
serving everybody serving in the uk
exclusive economic zone working in the
uk exclusive economic zone gets paid the
living wage as people do in the rest of
the country
yes
the problem is that's what he said two
years ago
it didn't happen a piano took advantage
of the gap left wide open by this prime
minister yes
piano's behavior comes off the back of a
string of fire and refi re-hire cases
profitable companies
threatening to fire workers unless they
accept a pay cut
the prime minister keeps telling us just
how opposed he is to fire and rehire
but as we saw on monday
as we saw
mr speaker as we saw on monday he
doesn't have the backbone to ban it
whilst he sits on his hands more and
more workers are having their lives
thrown upside down by this appalling
practice
what's good to them is a prime minister
who's all mouth and no trousers
the most notable practitioners of pharah
and rihar are of course the labour party
uh themselves uh but but i i can uh he
may be interested he may be interested
to know we will be vindicating the
rights of of british workers uh uk
employees under a uk law but the the law
that the pno cut the company themselves
are allegedly relying on uh was
introduced i can tell him as a result of
eu directives and
never
never forget never forget mr speaker
he may not like it that's the reality he
would have kept us he would have kept us
unable to change it unable to get out of
it uh he would have made it impossible
for us to protect uk employees in the
way that we're going to do but what
we're doing mr speaker above all is
ensuring that workers in this country
have the best protection of all which is
a job mr speaker and
under this government thanks to the
steps that we have taken thanks to the
stewardship of the economy by my right
honourable friend which you'll be
hearing about in a little bit more mr
speaker we have people in payroll
employment 600 000 more of them than
before the pandemic began
he can complain all he likes but on
monday he ordered all of his lot to
abstain on a vote to ban fire and rehire
exactly
and they all they all
did and then mr speaker
to add insult to injury after the vote
his party posted a message saying that
where possible they will look to find
piano workers new jobs
pathetic
they don't want new jobs
they want their old jobs back
they don't want a prime minister
hoisting the white flag they want him to
fight for their livelihoods
82 000 seafarers in this country i've
spoken to doctors engineers decades and
sailors they're all worried about what
this means for them this morning one of
them said to me if pno can get away with
this other companies will get rid of us
to
replace this with cheap labor from
abroad why does the prime minister think
that they will take a crumb of comfort
from his half-assed bluster and waffle
today
mr speaker piano plainly aren't going to
get away with it any more than any more
than anyone
any more than any other company that
treats his employees in that scandalous
way uh mr speaker and uh
this is a this is a historic moment for
this country actually uh because it's
now two years since uh two years to the
day uh that we went into lockdown and uh
that plunged this country into the
biggest uh deepest loss of output that
we've seen uh in our lifetimes and uh
thanks to the chancellor who protected
the economy who protected jobs who
protected companies
we've now been able to come out faster
and more effectively than any other
comparable economy we have unemployment
back down to 3.9 percent we have 600 000
more people on the payroll mr speaker
and the best assurance we can give
workers around the country is that the
economy is now bigger than it was before
the pandemic began and we will continue
to get the big calls right as we got the
big calls right uh during the pandemic
they got the big calls wrong they would
do absolutely nothing to protect workers
let alone piano workers and mr speaker
because because not only would they have
kept us in lockdown and kept those ships
in port mr speaker unable to move that's
the reality which kept those ships in
port but mr speaker there has never been
a labor government that left
left office with unemployment lower than
when they
began on jobs
[Music]